we've been telling you about nazin and
zagari ratcliffe she said that she was
forced to sign a false confession under
duress as a condition of her release
from iran she spent six years in prison
after being arrested on spying charges
that she had always contested uh
nazinen's
a friend of the program is with us now
as you can see hi richard it's great to
see you haven't chatted to you since um
she was uh released and brought back to
the uk how are things at home i bet the
baby's thrilled isn't she
yeah no that's right it's a much nicer
context to be having these kind of
interviews now um and as you say yeah
it's it's a whole new world for us um a
lot more relaxed um gabriella um very
pleased to have her mum and dad back you
know kind of
i don't think i appreciated how angry
she used to get
um now nothing's back much calm i mean
there's a bit more
navigating between the you know the
commands of two parents and rather than
just having to maneuver her dab around
her little finger
um but yeah
i think it's you know for all
of
the tensions of that first interview for
all of the tensions of the first
confessional internet now it's it's it's
a whole different world uh to be back
home
now talk to me um about what happened
before
she left iran and why she wants to talk
about that now
yeah so um just before leslie was left
uh was allowed to leave the country she
was taken on two occasions um on the
monday uh before she was taken
um to a revolutionary guard office in
the middle of the night about late
nights at 9 00 p.m until 11 p.m um and
was you know required to sign a false
confession which she resisted and she'd
been taken there by by british officials
um
wouldn't sign the confession that was
put in front of it it was a blank
template effectively where they would
fill in whatever they wanted to accuse
her of um wrote on something else um
said listen um this is what i was
convinced to acknowledge that i was
convicted of this
um
two days later at the airport again
another uh version of compassion was
brought in front of her um and this time
the british officials also said listen
if you want to get on that plane you
have to sign this um so very angry i was
you know um as as
sitting at home getting texts from her
since her furious doesn't happen
um
please that she's so um
hugely pleased that she's home but yeah
i think
it it was
startling um that the british government
also required her to sign that
confession
how concerned is she
by
making this public that there might be
challenges for her family back in iran
yeah i think she she was certainly
worried um i think
she
was worried anyway that it was going to
be used um in tv propaganda both in
terms of news pieces but also in terms
of drawing the series in other ways and
that was what she complained about both
to the foreign secretary um and to the
prime minister we met privately um and
yeah i think generally the criticism
she's made of the iranian authorities um
there's a worry as to what rebounds um
candidly i think it felt very important
that she did it there's a lot of people
friends she's got left behind sitting in
prison cells who are being abused in
horrible ways and she has a platform
where it's important to say that the
original authority is a completely out
of light um but yeah there's always a
risk of what happens next
i'm thrilled that she's back and uh that
family life is getting back to normal
for you thank you very much indeed for
joining us richard great to see you
thank you